and it's working on a lot of people you
know i i said
conservatives like to be really nice
guys so we like to say ah
look you can look we love our country by
waving the flag you love your country by
burning the flag but i can't i could
never say that you don't love your
country
this applies all the more so to religion
which is
in religion you say look
the catholic church your local
christian denomination your temple they
don't have
a political point of view religion has
nothing to say about politics
you can't have politics and religion or
religion and politics and of course
the left never respects that they try to
infiltrate the churches
with all of their leftism but it's never
allowed to go the other way
this has confused many many faithful
people
otherwise faithful people including jim
gaffigan who's
famously catholic his wife he refers to
as a shiite catholic
and jim gaffigan practices the faith as
well
i hope he does but he seems very
confused he just tweeted out
look trumpers i get it as a kid i was a
cubs fan and i know you stick by your
team no matter what but he's a traitor
and a con man who doesn't care about you
deep down you know it i'm sure you enjoy
pissing people off but you know trump is
a liar and a criminal
f lou holtz the baseball coach biden
is catholic in name only compared to who
how many abortions did trump pay for
how many women has he raped how many
times did he pull the s-h-i-t
he did in ukraine wake up he's a crook
he's a con man by the way no
evidence that he paid for abortions no
evidence that he raped women no evidence
that he did anything in ukraine we know
hunter biden and joe biden did but not
donald trump
wake up he's a crooked con man his
argument being
this this same stupid religious argument
word which is
you can't tell me that it's it's wrong
for
joe biden to pretend that he's a
catholic and then support abortions you
can't tell me that's
outrageous there's no right way to be a
catholic
that's there's there's no wrong way to
be a catholic at least there is
there is it is not acceptable
for catholics to vote for joe biden you
can't do it
you are imperiling your soul if you do
that
joe biden supports infanticide
up until the moment of birth paid for a
taxpayer expense
joe biden supports suing nuns he
faithfully served an administration
that sued nuns he promised if he's
elected again that he will sue more nuns
he persecutes the church there are many
other reasons too
a faithful catholic cannot vote for joe
biden
you are putting yourself in grave danger
if you do
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you